I really wanted to show the beauty of
another form of women you know that you
don't see usually and and that people do
not promote and I really wanted to show
how wonderful the flesh is and how
beautiful those women are and it was a
also really conscious effort to show
only parts of their body because I
wanted the person who would look at it
to see only that side and not the whole
and to show how beautiful the part can
be and it's as beautiful as a complete
form it's interesting because this is
the female form but most women will
recognize and why do you think the
fashion industry doesn't celebrate this
kind of form as much as the art world
well I think it's very sad that they
don't do it
I personally when I was in fashion never
did very very tight clothes because I
thought it was very uncomfortable and I
never I made a fashion show using size
zero models I you know it's unhealthy to
be so skinny it's not you know and it's
a wonderful to be able to eat what you
want to eat and enjoy life and this is
really glorious to see women and they
the two women who came to sit for me
they love to discover their body the way
I'm showing it you know they didn't
realize that there were so much beauty
in their legs in their torso in their
breasts and so I'm glad i exceeded in in
doing it and and that people can see how
beautiful it is how difficult was it for
you to change careers because not
difficult because it was always there
you know it was just I did my last
fashion show
six and a half years ago I think in
September at the next morning I was in
my studio and I never looked back I read
an article where you said on leaving
fashion behind that fashion wasn't fun
anymore and I just wonder if you keep an
eye on the industry I mean obviously
you're immersed in all of this now in
terms of you know top designers names
like yourself are struggling they are
perhaps not making as much money as they
used to and high street brands are
falling by the wayside it does seem that
fashion whether it's high end or high
street isn't fun anymore yeah I don't
really follow the only thing I can see
is a lot of my friends in fashion have
been disheartened and they have left and
wondering what they're gonna do next I
can see when I Drive or when I walk that
some stores in the high street have
closed and obviously it's very very hard
and makes me think I left at the right
moment I know that you created curated
an exhibition that yeah chaos that you
know the title itself attention-grabbing
and heavily influenced by events going
on in the world at the time regarding
brexit and the rise it was Donald Trump
yeah that was before because it was two
and a half years ago I think I did that
sure yeah because of course there is a
lot of chaos in the world and it came to
me very very easily to curate a show
called chaos and it's very sad because
I'm where is your sculpture going to
take you next I'm not gonna tell anyone
until it's started and I mean I'm
starting now because I couldn't wait for
the work to leave the studio so I have
the space again and I can start so next
week that's it I will start now I know I
always know and I think it's probably
because when you are in fashion you have
to think about what's coming next you
can't steadily have a fashion show and
then the next day say oh and now what
are we going to do
you know you have not even before the
end of a show you have to have started -
who knows fabrics you know it takes a
long time to make a collection so the
same when I work on something I'm
already thinking next and I've started
doing something but not completed
anything yet so well something's from
fashion never leave you then they call
for it when I should to speak to you
today thank you so much thank you thank
you